In talking about, in talking about black holes,
of course.
Stephen Hawking is the great scientist who
comes to mind, so I'd like to spend a little
bit of time thinking about what it is that
Hawking told us about black holes.
What were the insights that he gave us, and
what puzzles emerged from his work that we
are still struggling to resolve and probably
will continue to struggle with for some time?
And toward that end, as a little bit of background,
we need to have some understanding of a concept
that everybody is familiar with it at some
level or another, but let's use this opportunity
to get us all in the same place.
And that's a concept of entropy.
So entropy is a word that's free, they used,
and the culture, we often use it to describe
a certain amount of going from order to disorder,
that's going from low entropy to high entropy.
That's sort of the intuition that the culture
has about this word.
So let's start with that very basic way of
thinking about entropy.
And a good example would be, let's say I take
my book, I throw it up in the air, it starts
very ordered.
All the pages were in complete, numerical
order, but as they come down, it's overwhelmingly
likely that they will not land in numerical
order.
They'll land in a highly disordered state
and that gives you some sense of what it means
to go from an ordered arrangement to a highly
disordered arrangement, going from low entropy
to higher entropy.
Now, of course, that's just a sort of fanciful,
everyday example.
If we head more toward a physics example,
we could imagine having a box of gas, and
imagine it has a small number of atoms in
there, and imagine that they're all neatly
arranged in this nice cubic lattice.
This would be a very ordered or low entropy
configuration of the gas, like the pages all
in numerical order.
Now, contrast that with a box of gas that
has a whole lot of atoms, a whole lot of particles
are all bouncing around in a completely haphazard
way.
This would be a very disordered state, a high
entropy state.
And another way of thinking about the distinction
between low entropy and high entropy, which
we'll be making use of in just a moment is
the amount of information that would be required
to describe these two configurations.
Because look on the left, you don't need a
lot of data.
It's a cubic lattice.
You've got three by three by three atom filling
out that lattice.
And if I gave you the separation of them,
say 10 centimeters, that basically describes
the configuration on the left.
You don't need a lot of information to describe
the system that has low entropy.
But let's say I want to describe the configuration
on the right.
Well, I basically have to tell you where each
and every particle is located.
That's the only way I could describe it.
Look at all the information I need to describe
that configuration.
So the idea is low entropy, not a lot of information.
High entropy takes a lot of information that's
hidden in this configuration of particles
and that's kind of the distinction between
order, disorder, low entropy, high entropy,
low information, high information.
Now of course I'm talking in loose language
so that we can all get a feel for the critical
ideas, but you can make this all quite precise.
And this gentleman over here, you know who
this is?
Who's this?
Ludwig Boltzmann.
That's right.
And this is his, his famous tombstone, and
you see that formula on the top of his tombstone,
and that is the formula that makes these statements
precise.
This is a formula that you learn if you take
a course in statistical mechanics, thermodynamics.
S stands for entropy.
K is Boltzmann's constant, and the rest of
it has to do with the number of configuration
of the ingredients of the particles that make
up the system.
You.
You got a job at Harvard as faculty, but that's
okay.
We're still.
We're still good-
You are doing very well too.
Thank you.
And I should say my most exciting intellectual
adventures in string theory have been the
papers that we have done together.
A lot of fun with you Brian.
Thank you.
So it's been an honor to work with you.
So thank you.
So, so let's, let's now get into this subject
here.
We heard a little bit about entropy and about
the second law that entropy increases over
time, but in the 1970s, people like Bekenstein
and, and Hawking, and they began to worry
about how the second law of thermodynamics
would behave in the environment of a black
hole.
And give us a sense of what they were puzzling
about.
You.
You got a job at Harvard as faculty, but that's
okay.
We're still.
We're still good-
You are doing very well too.
Thank you.
And I should say my most exciting intellectual
adventures in string theory have been the
papers that we have done together.
A lot of fun with you Brian.
Thank you.
So it's been an honor to work with you.
So thank you.
So, so let's, let's now get into this subject
here.
We heard a little bit about entropy and about
the second law that entropy increases over
time, but in the 1970s, people like Bekenstein
and, and Hawking, and they began to worry
about how the second law of thermodynamics
would behave in the environment of a black
hole.
And give us a sense of what they were puzzling
about.
So part of the puzzle was the objects they
knew falls into the black holes, but they
cannot come out.
So objects that are falling in have entropy,
just like what Brian already described, you
have some information about where they are,
how they are, but once you fall into a black
hole then you don't have anymore access to
that information.
So what happened to that information?
So that seems like you lost entropy.
Entropy went down and that's against what
Boltzmann said.
So can you give a concrete example of that?
So I think we have a little silly example.
If I took my wallet, it has information, it
has entropy.
I throw it into the black hole and you're
asking what happened to that entropy?
Did it disappear from the universe?
Exactly.
So that was the kind of question that they
were struggling to understand.
How could this be consistent?
Right.
So, uh, they began thinking about this and
then there were a few ideas that they were
thinking about, and in particular the properties
of the horizon of a black hole-
The edge.
The edge, the event horizon that we thought-
The edge in which- beyond which you can- no
light can escape.
They found it had some interesting properties,
and in particular they began studying what
is the area, and what is the area of this
edge, and how does it change.
And in particular, what happens if you throw
objects into this black hole, what happens
to this area?
And one of the surprising things they found
was that when you throw objects in, this area
cannot stay put, and in fact increases.
Yep.
So they began to think about, okay, what could
this mean about this- What, what this could
be related in some way compensated by the
fact that you're losing something, the entropy.
Could it be somehow compensated by the fact
that this area is growing?
So they begin to ask the question, could the
area of this event horizon be in any way related
to the lost entropy?
So we actually can unpack that.
So let's just go through a couple of little
examples here.
So this is the standards.
Second Law of thermodynamics.
Entropy grows over time.
Let's just take the two boxes that I started
with to illustrate what you're describing.
If we take those two boxes and they put them
together, what happened to the entropy?
It goes up.
The Boltzmann's thing.
Right.
So we have the combined entropy is greater
than the individuals entropy.
Great.
Now you're describing something that doesn't
have to do with gas in a box.
You're talking about the geometry of a black
hole.
So for example, they studied what happens
if you study one black hole with one area
of event horizon and another black hole with
a different area, and you bring them together,
you merge them and you get a new black hole
with a new area.
And they found that the area of the new formed
black hole is bigger than the sum of the two
areas, just like the entropy had that property.
The entropy resulting in the box when you
combined them was bigger than the individual
entropies.
So the entropy sounded very similar to the
area, or areas sounded very similar to the
entropy.
So they began asking, could it be that the
area and entropy are proportional to one another
for black holes?
And indeed they found a formula that we can
bring up here.
So entropy is the area, and the proportionality
constant is a little bit complicated but you
don't really have to worry too much about
that, this number on the right hand side,
but the basic lesson is that they're guessing,
they're suggesting that the area of the event
horizon is somehow holding on to the entropy,
holding onto the information in some sense
that's inside the black hole.
Now you gave an interesting thought experiment
about how to test that.
You're talking about throwing something in
and watching the area, and it just so happens
that we have a little segment on that here.
So why don't we go through that.
So here's a-.
So take us.
So what are we seeing here?
And then we'll do your little thought experiment.
So here I guess are seeing a black hole.
The red black hole.
Yes, exactly.
With the event horizon of it, you can see
that the idea that the information is proportional
to the area with some proportionality constant.
If each individual element of the information
is like one square there, we just divided
this sphere into these areas.
So these represent bits of information on
that surface of that black hole.
So those little squares can roughly speaking,
be thought of as Planck areas.
These in the Planck length that described
sort of the smallest length that makes sense
in a, in a quantum theory of gravity.
Squares of the size 10 to the minus 33 centimeters
or so if you want to.
Yeah.
Each side of the square is so-
So you basically count the number of those
little squares that are on the event horizon,
and that's the amount of entropy it has.
So if we now took- If this is true, and we
were to take a particle that sort of carried
one unit of entropy, what would we expect
to happen if this is true?
We expect this area to grow exactly by one
square.
So let's, let's sort of do that.
We have- This is actually a real real film
of, of space here.
So let's get our particle going in to this
guy over here.
Good.
So the one on the left was the original black
hole.
The one on the right is the larger one after
particles fall in.
So if we take all those little squares, and
we smear them out on the larger black hole,
what we'd expect to happen, something like
that.
Exactly.
So one one more square.
So we throw a sort of one particle in that
carries one unit of disorder, and the black
hole eats it.
It grows a little bit, and in fact you can
calculate that the amount by which it will
expand can accommodate one more of these little
tiles.
And that makes us a consistent way of thinking
about black balls.
So.
So this was like an important- How, I mean,
how important was, was this kind of an insight?
Well, this was the amazing inside because
it was the first time where Einstein's theory
of relativity was combined with quantum effects.
And that is what Hawking used to actually
argue that the entropy of a black hole has
something to do with the area.
And so this combination of quantum theory
and Einstein's theory was quite novel, and
this was in early seventies, mid sevens.
So is this the end of the story when it comes
to entropy and black holes?
Like what, what, what issues does this leave
over?
Well actually the problem was that Hawking's
argument showed that there must be information,
but on the other hand, the horizon of a black
hole is featureless, so you don't see these
points, squares or anything.
So there seems to be no room for information
to be stored on it.
So in fact, if you use Einstein's equations
and solve it, you find there is exactly one
solution for a spherical symmetric black hole.
One solution means it has zero entropy.
It's exactly ordered state.
There's no choice.
One piece of information.
And that is inconsistent with what Hawking
found when he combined Einstein's theory of
quantum mechanics, where he found a huge amount
of information.
And the question is where is this huge amount
of information stored?
Is it the shape of the horizon, or is it-
What aspect of black hole encodes the microscopic
structure of the black hole that was open
when Hawking discovered this fact.
So, so for Hawking's idea to work, let's just
go back to my little example of sort of throwing
the wallet in.
So, so in that little example I threw the
wallet and he said where did the information
go?
So, so the new idea, if it's true, would be
I take my wallet and I throw it in and rather
than it disappearing, the idea roughly speaking
would be the information that is in my wallet,
the configuration of all the atoms and molecules
that goes toward the black hole.
And we want it to be the case that that information
kind of like smears itself out on the outside
and is encoded in sort of bits, ones and zeros.
That's the picture.
And the principal were this true, I could
actually extract that information in principle
and use it to rebuild anything that fell in.
In this case it'd be my wallet.
So that's the idea.
That's if the information is not lost, that
information is there.
That's what we would expect.
Yes.
That's the hole.
And the puzzle is, is that actually-
Is that actually true?
And how do you actually see this information
and where is it stored?
Or how do you account for the microstates
of the black hole or the entropy of the black
hole?
And that's where you come in.
Well me and my colleagues and string theory
began studying these questions more seriously
with the advent of duality, some interests
in string theory.
So firstly-
Can you say a few words about string theory?
I should say a few words about string theory.
So string theory is, is a framework where
we believe combines Einstein's theory of relativity
with quantum theory in a consistent framework.
And as part of it, it demands that the entities
making up the matter is not, are not just
point particles, but entities like strings
or membranes or extended objects have to play
a key role.
And so that's one aspect of string theory.
It is a little, if you want to take us through-
This is just a little example, what string
theory might look like.
So you've got a piece of matter, and we're
going to dive into it.
And then you're saying that if it goes sufficiently
deep-
So if you go to the beginning, inside, you'll
see the atoms first.
And uh, you know, inside the atoms you see
the nucleus.
And the nucleus you see here, like it's the
protons and neutrons, I'm assuming.
Then you go inside them, you see the quarks,
and once you see the quark you can go inside
them, and if you zoom in further you might
see actually that these featureless quarks
that you think are point particle actually
are tiny strings, vibrating strings of some
sort, and that's the kind of a picture that
we expect to be true in the context of string
theory.
That point particles are point-like because
we are not zoomed in sufficiently close to
them, and if you zoom in enough, they will
have features like strings.
How big would those-
We don't know exactly, but it could be like
10 to the minus 30 centimeter- It's somewhat
close to the Planck scale that we discussed
already in the context of the areas of the
horizon of the black hole.
So that's the basic feature of string theory,
but as one of the aspects of string theory
that was originally one of the negative features,
was that string theory predicted that the
spatial dimension of the universe is not three,
and that was manifested in contradiction with
the fact that we think we live in three spatial
dimensions.
We have three spatial dimensions.
String theory seem to demand that we have
nine spatial dimensions, and so this was a
contradiction originally, and physicists thought
how could this possibly work?
And one resolution was, oh, these extra- six
extra dimensions that we have are so tiny,
like little circles at every point in space.
Let's imagine six dimensions, six circles
at each point, six types of circles which
are so tiny that you cannot see.
So the idea would be the macroscopic dimensions
are only three.
The big ones are three, but the tiny ones
are six.
And the tiny ones are hard to see unless you
really zoom in and that's difficult to do
with the energies that are available to us
in our experiments today.
But the idea would be there.
You've got these, these big dimensions that
we know about.
These extra dimensions, and then how do you
relate this to this idea of black hole?
this was actually a negative feature for string
theory.
So string theorists were kind of struggling.
Yeah, we have these six extra dimension.
It's a little embarrassing.
It's tiny.
You don't see them.
And then other people said, sure, sure, yes,
yes.
So this was the state of the art to mid-nineties
where we didn't know what to do with these
extra dimensions.
They were there just to make the theory consistent
and we were hiding it away in tiny little
things.
And then came the question about the black
holes and the black hole had the opposite
problem.
The problem with the black hole was we were
missing information of the black hole.
So where were they?
What were that information?
It turned out that these two problems canceled
each other out.
And so this- the problem that was where are
they in-?
Where are the ingredients or the degrees of
freedom that constitutes black hole ended
up in the internal spatial, tiny spacial things
that I was talking about.
So as you can see here, the red, donut shape
object, there is to represent these tiny internal
dimensions.
And the blue sheet that you see represents
the macroscopic three macroscopic dimensions.
And so the idea there is that if you take
a string or a membrane or one of these extended
objects and wrap it around the cycles on these
external tiny spaces like a torus or like
a circle or donut or whatnot shape you have,
it will create a mass at the point where you're
wrapping around that circle, and the more
it wraps around, the more mass is going to
be constituting there, and the more it's gonna
shape and distort the geometry of space around
it.
And if that is enough of it, it's going to
create this warped space, which is what we
call the black hole.
So the black hole itself can be viewed as
these strings or membranes wrapped around
these extra cycles of this tiny space.
And so then if the question is what accounts
for the degrees of freedom of the black hole
it are, these are precisely the strings or
membranes wrapped around these extra dimensions.
How many are there?
How many degrees of freedom are there?
What are the entropy?
Gets translated to how many ways these extra
strings or membranes can wrap around these
extra dimensions.
And there are many ways and that accounted
for the entropy of the black hole.
So with Andy- Andy Strominger and I did actually
a computation of how much entropy is there
in these wrappings of these string around
the external, around these internal dimensions
of string theory.
And we found exact match with a prediction
that Beckenstein and Hawking had made about
the entropy of these black holes.
So just to quickly unpack a little bit.
So, so basically you found a new way of describing
black holes in string theory, which makes
use of the extra curled up dimensions.
The red part of this image that we find here.
And you're saying that by wrapping these strings
or ingredients of string theory around the
extra dimensions, you can create a warping
in space that looks just like the black hole
that we've been talking about for many years
before string theory even was on anybody's
mind.
But in this description you can do a direct
count of the amount of information necessary
to describe the situation and bang on, it
matches what Hawking said.
Yes.
So, so this gives us insight into one possible
way of describing the internal structure of
a black hole, which in many ways I think they,
the community views as one of the most important
pieces of data that string theory may be going
in the right direction.
We don't have experimental support for these
ideas, but here's a mathematical piece of
experimental support, if you will, that it
matches ideas that had been on the table for
25, 30 years.
So.
So this is a key step forward, but now let's
turn to some of the puzzles that still remain
and part of the puzzles surround something
that's tightly related to what we've been
talking about, which is something called Hawking
radiation.
Can you just tell us a bit about what Hawking
radiation is?
So Hawking after discovering the properties
of having information in the black and the
entropy, he also noticed that the black hose
actually are not quite black.
And what happens if you go near the event
horizon of the black hole.
What happens is that you get pairs of particles
created out of vacuum.
These are quantum fluctuations, the quantum
fluctuations always creating particles and
antiparticles in pairs, and typically they
go in and out without doing anything, but
if they are near the event horizon, one of
them per chance could go towards the inside
of the black hole and then one of them could
go outside.
And the moment she goes inside has no way
of getting out, so stuck there, but the one
going out so can leave and go far away from
it all the way to infinity, and that looks
like a radiation from the viewpoint of somebody
outside.
So in other words, from the viewpoint of somebody
outside, the black hole is actually radiating
energy.
As it radiates energy, it loses mass, and
it shrinks and shrinks and shrinks, until
after a while the black hole totally disappears
where there's no more energy left to, to emit.
So once the, once the black hole disappears,
the question is what happens to all that information
that went into the black hole?
What happened to that area was talking about?
Where is that information gone?
So this was a question that Hawking basically
posed, perhaps you recall the discussion between
Einstein and Bohr that uh, Einstein did not
like the probabilistic aspect of quantum mechanics.
And so he said, God does not play dice.
And Niels Bohr responded by saying to Einstein,
stopped telling God what to do, and uh, Hawking
added his own wrinkle on this.
He said, well, what happens if you throw a
dice inside the black hole, and the black
hole after a while disappears and with it
disappears the dice?
So, and then he said, not only does God throw
dice, he sometimes throws it, throws them
where they cannot be seen.
And then you made a little little cake for
him.
mWe had the lucky occasion of having a Stephen
Hawking as our guests at his home a couple
of years ago when he was visiting Harvard,
and then we made the cake in the form of a
black hole with a dice.
And the book, his famous book, which is actually
made of- It's a cake and it's actually gluten
free because he was allergic.
So, so, so Stephen had his cake and he could
eat it too.
So yeah.
So in that, in that picture, you see that
there are two, two dice hanging there floating
towards the black hole, and it's going in
and that's the, the issue of the information
puzzle.
You lose the information of what, what is
the dice roll, and uh, that's what's called
the information puzzle because if the dice
rolls some number and the black hole evaporates,
it disappears.
With it disappears the information about what
the role of the dice was, and that's called
the information posture, which we still are
struggling to understand even today.
Now, most people in the field for a long time
have anticipated that somehow the information
does get out with that radiation that we saw
coming off of the black hole.
Now for a while, Stephen Hawking said that
the information would, would not command-
And that quote was quite serious.
He was saying that we have to rethink quantum
mechanics because the information does not
come back out.
He then changed his mind on that.
Yes.
So part of the reason for this is the discovery
of a more detailed version of what is called
holography.
In other words, this, this began with the
work already back in the, in the long time
ago, but became more precise with the work
of one mother center where it was discovered
how that you can describe a gravitational
system precisely using objects which are much
simpler to understand.
And in particular in that system you could
prove mathematically rigorously, there's no
way you can lose information.
So therefore, indirectly there was a proof
that whatever happens to black holes, the
information should get out.
So that part was kind of beginning to be established
using these kinds of arguments and string
theory.
But the wrinkle is that even though there's
this mathematical proof that this should happen,
we still did not know exactly how, and some
people thought maybe the information gets
out with this radiation, as you were saying,
Brian, very gradually and very tiny bit at
a time, but gradually builds up to give you
information out.
And this is what, uh, in the early 2000s,
I believe, Stephen agreed that this is the
resolution.
But I still think, and I think the community
still believes we haven't really understood
how this happens exactly.
So the information puzzle about how this information
comes out is still one of the big mysteries
of black holes, and we don't really understand
it.
So do you think it's possible that we will
one day conclude that the original view of
Hawking was right, that the information does
not get at?
Is that still on the table in your view?
Well, I think it sounds much less likely given
that we think we understand a dual description
and other description of these black holes.
So it seems like that seems much less likely
now, but you know, we can never say we know
everything about the subject.
That's our current understanding.
It could of course evolve, but even even with
that understanding, it's not- Our understanding
is not sufficiently detailed to convince us
of this, of how it happens.
Now a lot of our discussion here has been
focusing on what happens at the edge of a
black hole, at the event horizon to a black
hole that it may be where the information
is stored, that may be where the entropy is
stored.
We haven't said much about what happens at
the center.
Can we just spend a little time talking about
that?
Well, one of the things that happens in the
center of the black hole is that there's this
singularity, this infinity that Brian discussed
already, this division by zero analogy, and
we don't believe that's physical.
We believe that's just the phantom of our
equation.
It's just the mathematical thing that comes
out and that means that our description breaks
down.
Not that there is an infinity.
Now quickly, the infinity could be physically
that you've got all this mass crushed to zero
size.
Zero size is not physical.
Yes for us, there nothing smaller than Planck's
length, which is about 10 to the minus 33
centimeters.
The notion of space breaks down anything smaller
than that, so there cannot be an infinity
in physics, we don't believe so, so we don't
understand what is happening at that, at that
in that way.
And the understanding of this singularity,
we are not at all close to understanding what's
happening there.
We know that there should be a good description,
but we don't have it.
And why that's important is that, well, we
want to know what's happening inside the black
holes.
Of course we can send somebody and find out
what happens to that infinity, but that would
not be a fair thing.
And even if we did that, even if we said,
well, we send some creature not us, the robot
or something, the robot cannot come back to
tell us what happened or what they saw.
So because nothing can escape from black holes.
So it won't be useful.
So we have to figure it out without going
inside the black hole, what's going on there,
and that's still, we have no, uh, not only
you don't have observational data, we don't
have enough theoretical understanding.
And we think it's important not just for the
black holes, but it turns out that those infinities
that we see, if you try to pass through those
infinities to the other side, so to speak,
it turns out it looks very much like the infinities
we see at the beginning of our own universe.
It is as if our universe is emerging from
inside of one of these black holes.
Along those lines.
And don't lose your train of thought there.
Oftentimes people think of the center of the
black hole as a location in space.
The center.
Is that the right way of-
No, actually it's like in a given time, it
happens at a given time and that's because
the nature of space and time changes as you
enter the black hole.
When you cross the event horizon of the black
hole.
So one of the reasons why you can't get out
is because you can't stop time from ticking
forward.
Exactly.
So going forward and forward in time is like
going closer and closer to the singularity-
And then at certain time you hit the singularity.
That's the time.
It's at the given time is that-
So the singularity could be the end of time
in some sense.
It could be, but we don't believe that.
And then what you would say what's the after
that, and that looks very much like what could
be a new universe or something.
So we are interested in understanding the
resolution to the issue of singularity of
black holes, and I think it's very exciting.
We know that black holes, as we discussed
already in this program, there are huge amount
of evidence that they exist or they are there.
We cannot say.
We're just imagining.
So what is that?
What is a singularity?
What are we learning from it?
This one of the most beautiful, mysterious
objects I think in the universe, and hopefully,
by some experiments and maybe by some theoretical
understanding, we will have some progress
in that.
So what's your guess?
I mean if we come back and we invite you back
for the, I dunno, the 2025 World Science Festival,
can you give us the answer to what happens
at the center of a black hole?
Maybe invite in 2050 if I'm alive.
2050.
All right.
Good.
A good prediction.
A safe prediction.
Please join me in thanking Cumrun Vafa.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Fantastic.
Goodnight everybody.
Thank you.